The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, our goal
is to really go through this
the paper that you
read maybe last night
by Dekel and Alon "Optimality
and Evolutionary Tuning
of the Expression
Level of a Protein."
It was published
in Nature in 2005.
I think that it's a very
interesting paper, exploring
some kind of big general ideas.
I think it's also, in some
ways, rather misleading.
And we'll try to
understand or discuss
the ways in which the
connections between experiment,
theory, prediction,
and so forth,
how they all play out in
the context of this problem.
Before we get going too
much on the science,
I just want to remind
everyone that Andrew will not
be having office hours today.
He is off interviewing for
MD, PhD programs right now.
But if you had questions
about the problems,
I hope that you asked
[? Sarab ?] last night.
You might be able to grab
him after the lecture
today, but yes.
Any other questions about
anything before we get going?
No.
So I think that this
paper in general, I guess,
the lecture today is
really a combination
of trying to start thinking
about maybe laboratory
evolution or kind of population
level phenomena in general,
as well as this
question of optimization
in terms of protein expression.
So can somebody
just maybe summarize
the big idea of this paper?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Protein
expression levels
evolve to optimal values
for cost-benefit questions.
PROFESSOR: Right, so that's
the argument at least.
And they have a very
nice first sentence here.
"Different proteins have
different expression levels."
You know, it's hard to
argue with that statement,
nice, concise.
But the question is, well, why?
And I'd say that
there is a range,
different philosophical
opinions out in the world.
I said that some group
that is very much reflected
in this study is trying
to think about this
in the context of optimization.
Well, maybe the reason that we
see a given level of expression
of some protein is because, at
least over evolutionary time,
in some ancestral environment
that we don't know, but maybe
it evolved to optimize
some cost-benefit problem.
And then I'd say that
there's another kind
of general
philosophical approach
that tends to be a little
bit more agnostic or just
maybe more of a sense that
certainly things could have
evolved to optimize something.
But we can never really
know where they evolved in,
so we shouldn't be going out
on a limb on these things.
And given that
this is philosophy,
I will maybe not
require that you agree
with any particular standpoint.
But I will say that it's
at least worth thinking
about the question
and maybe you can
do measurements to illuminate
whether all these ideas might
make sense.
And then we'll try to, over
the next hour and a half,
figure out to what degree this
paper maybe should convince us
of this optimization
in the context
of this particular protein.
Now, even if it's the
case that somebody
convinces you maybe that
expression of the lac operon
maybe does optimize some
cost-benefit analysis.
That does not prove that
every protein optimize things.
So don't get overwhelmed
or underwhelmed
or whatever it might be.
Let's just first
make sure that we
understand what we mean by
costs and benefits in this case.
Can somebody pick one of them?
Now, what is a cost and
benefit in the context
of maybe this paper?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Producing protein
requires some kind of resource.
PROFESSOR: Right, requires--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] energy--
PROFESSOR: --requires resources
of some sort or another
to express these proteins.
And this can manifest
in many different ways.
But certainly, if you were
not making these proteins,
you could have been making
some other proteins.
And so if these proteins
are not helping you, then
maybe something else would have.
But they're are many different
ways of looking at this.
But there is some finite number
of things that the cell can do.
And the benefits, of course,
in the case-- and this
is in particular in
the case of a lac
operon, what does this
network allow us to do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You get to consume
the energy of lactose.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Lets you go faster.
PROFESSOR: That's right,
you get to consume lactose
in this case.
Now, we've already spent some
time thinking or discussing
the lac operon.
What were the two key components
in here in the lac operon?
If you were a cell and
you wanted to eat lactose,
what would you need to do?
I'm picking somebody
to-- yes, please.
AUDIENCE: It's a gene that you
should express, the lac gene?
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So the lac genes.
But maybe in a little
bit more detail,
what do we mean when
we say the lac genes?
Well, I mean, it's
not just lactose.
But I mean, what
are the things that
have to happen if you want
to eat anything, I guess?
Your cell--
AUDIENCE: Import.
PROFESSOR: Right, so you
first have to import it.
Now, in some cases, this can
be done maybe for some-- maybe
nutrients, it could be
done even passively,
if it crosses the
membrane easily.
But for most of the things
that you might think about,
you actually have
to do active import.
So this is done by what?
Anybody remember?
lacY.
So lacY is a membrane
protein that imports lactose.
And then what do you need to do?
AUDIENCE: Break the two apart,
and then you can metabolize.
PROFESSOR: Right, then you
have to eat it somehow.
Now, of course, metabolism
is a very complicated thing.
But the key thing that's
different between lactose
and maybe the simple
sugars is that you first
have to break down the lactose
into its constituent parts.
A lactose is a
disaccharide composed
of two simple monosaccharides.
So what you need is you need
this lacZ, beta-galactosidase,
in order to cleave that bond.
And then you have the two
simple monosaccharides
that can be eaten.
Now, the lac operon
also has this lacA.
And it's not quite obvious
what that thing does,
so nobody ever talks about it.
But there is a
third protein there.
But what we always
talk about is lacY,
that's require to import the
lactose and then lacZ that
is required to break the lactose
down into its monosaccharides.
And then the idea-- and
that's not sufficient.
You don't take those
monosaccharides
and instantly make
more cells out of it.
But the idea is that the rest
of the metabolic machinery
is kind of there any
ways to do other-- that's
kind of some assumptions.
Can somebody explain how it
is that they measured the cost
of expressing these proteins?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So they [INAUDIBLE]
expressed these proteins
at different levels using
different concentrations
of IPTG.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: There was
no lactose around,
so it was only the
cost to no benefits.
And then they
measured [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right, perfect.
OK, so there are several
key things in here.
So first of all,
normally, what we do
is it's lactose inside the
cell that causes this lac
repressor to fall
off and then you get
expression of the lac operon.
But in order to kind of
sidestep or circumvent
that normal network, what
we are doing in this case
is adding IPTG.
So IPTG allows one to
get expression of--
and what IPTG is that it stops
the inhibition of this lac
promoter, where you
get lacZ and lacY.
Now, the idea here
is that you can
control the level of
expression of this operon,
because what we
really want is we
want to measure a
plot of something
that you would call cost--
and we'll explore a little bit
more what that means-- as a
function of the lac operon
expression.
And this is often done
relative to the full induction
of the wild type lac operon.
And this is a relative
growth rate reduction.
So basically, this
is a percentage,
say, decrease in growth rate.
Now, there was a key
thing that you brought up,
which is that you want
to measure the growth
rate in the absence of lactose.
Because otherwise as we
increase the level of expression
here-- so we're
controlling this by IPTG,
so there's some mapping
from IPTG concentration
to the level of expression here.
But we want to be able
to measure the cost
separate from the benefits.
So it's important then to grow
this in the absence of lactose.
So say, no lactose.
But if I just take
bacteria and I put them
in a tube with say
minimal media, salt,
so forth, but no lactose,
are they going to grow?
They need to draw something.
So what is it that
the authors have done?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Glycerol.
PROFESSOR: That's right,
they added some glycerol
and in different parts.
I think it's 1% glycerol.
Does anybody happen to remember?
I think, for most
of it, it was 0.1%.
I tell you what,
we'll say a little bit
of small concentrations
of glycerol.
So the idea is that this is kind
of a second rate carbon source.
The bacteria are not super
happy, but they're OK.
And then given this,
what they were able
demonstrate is that, if
they did add lactose,
they would have grown faster.
So there's a sense that the
lactose does help the cells.
But you have to
have some glycerol.
Otherwise, you can't really
measure these things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is it that-- you
were saying if you put like
a very good carbon source--
PROFESSOR: Well--
AUDIENCE: You're not going
to see any [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so first
of all what I was saying
is that you have to
have some carbon source.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Right, so you
have to do something.
And it's just good
conceptually to make
sure you think about
how you would actually
do this experiment.
Now, you have to add
some carbon source.
But the question is, well,
what happens if you just
added a bunch of glucose?
Now, in that case actually, for
some of the other experiments,
I think that would have
caused problems in the sense
that then there would not
be any benefits associated
with growing or with adding
increasing lac operon
expression.
For this experiment,
in principle,
one could have done
that, although you really
want to measure the costs
and associated benefits
in some environment,
which you're
to be doing in
later experiments.
So I think it's really from
a conceptual standpoint,
in principle, you can
measure this in glucose,
but then you'd always worry,
oh, well, maybe it's different.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, right.
So you could have broken down--
So the other issue is that,
in principle-- and they
don't talk about this here--
but yeah, if you add a
bunch of glucose, then
you would have to have
another mutant in order
to break the glucose
repression, because if you
have this preferred
carbon source,
glucose, then you'll
naturally repress the CRP, all
of the alternative modes
of carbon metabolism
just because glucose
was kind of the best.
And what was the key conclusion
from this first data plot?
AUDIENCE: It's nonlinear.
PROFESSOR: All right, nonlinear.
The cost is a function
of the lac expression.
And it grows super linearly.
I always forget
what the difference
is in concave and convex is.
I don't know if other people
have this particular brain
problem.
But the second
derivative is positive.
In particular, that
means that if you
do draw some sort
of like line, then
they have data that looks
something like-- so here
is 0.5.
We have something that
kind of falls below here.
They had about a 0.25.
And it was also a little
bit below that crossed.
They had a 0.75.
And then they had a 1.
Why is it that they
can't go above 1 here?
Why do they not have
more data out here?
AUDIENCE: Because you
can't have more expression
than full expression.
PROFESSOR: You can't have more
expression than full expression
with this promoter,
because what they are doing
is they're adding
IPTG, so they titrate
between 0 and maximal
expression from this promoter.
In principle, you could
always get another one.
And then you should be able
to go out further, right?
And at maximal
expression, they measure
about a 4% growth
deficit, 0.04, just
to give you a sense of scale.
So this is 4% deficit.
Now, I want to ask a
more general question.
So let's imagine that you
are measuring some quantity.
So we'll say this is some
quality y as a function of x.
And let's imagine that the
true y as a function of x
looks like something.
Now, you go and you
measure at multiple values
of x this curve, because
we're very interested in what
this curve looks like.
Now, the question is, what
fraction of the error bars
will contain this
curve and, of course,
contain this is true curve?
So I'm assuming that this curve
is the god-given actual thing
that you're measuring.
And so you measure this
quantity with noise.
So we measure this some number
of times, some number of times.
Do you understand the question?
So here, contained the curve.
There, it didn't.
So what fraction of error
bars will contain that curve?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
And indeed, what we
want-- it's always good--
what were the error bars
in the figure 2A in this?
Right, well, OK, so they're
experimental error, right.
Incidentally, how is
it that they actually
measure these things?
Does anybody-- And
so these are actually
a result of growing on
a nice [INAUDIBLE] well,
like a microtiter
plate, where they
used a checkerboard pattern.
And they take 48
different cultures.
And they measure
the growth rates
for each one individually.
And then they're plotting the
standard error of the mean.
Do you understand what
I'm trying to ask you?
AUDIENCE: So in
that case, I mean,
the size of the error bars,
you just want a scaling
or something,
[? if that's right, ?] because
the size of the error bars--
PROFESSOR: Right, well--
AUDIENCE: I just--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, so
this is a good question.
We'll find out.
So it depends on n, where
n is the number of samples
that we took at each location.
Question, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the standard
error is just the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right, so standard
error of the mean, this
is an important question.
What you do is you calculate
the standard deviation, divide
by the square root
of n-- OK, now,
I always forget whether
it's n or n minus 1, now.
We already did one
n minus 1, right?
So it's you measure
the standard deviation
of the data, the standard
deviation in y divided
by root n, where n is the
number of measurements
you took at that point.
But of course, when you
measure the standard deviation,
there was already
an n minus 1, right?
Have I lost a minus 1?
Do you guys-- OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the standard--
I thought the standard error
of the mean and not the actual
standard deviation [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And we're going to spend a
lot of time talking about what
the difference is between
a standard deviation
and a standard
error of the mean.
And it depends on what
you're trying to ask.
Do you guys understand what
I'm trying to ask here?
All right, well, let's
just see where we are,
and then we'll discuss.
OK, ready?
3, 2, 1.
All right, so we got
many A's, B's, C's.
Nobody likes D. OK, but it's
very common to see that.
Let's go ahead and--
it's worthwhile,
I think there's enough
variation to decide.
And in particular,
between your neighbor,
try to agree on
why or why not it
might depend on n and so forth.
We'll just have a minute
to think about this.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
PROFESSOR: So what
do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: We're
still [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, no, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
PROFESSOR: Why don't we
go ahead and reconvene,
so we can kind of try to figure
out what is going on here.
I just want to
see if anybody has
changed their opinion as
a result of discussing
with their neighbor.
All right, let's see it.
3, 2, 1.
Some people are not even
willing to-- all right,
OK, so it's interesting.
So now, actually,
it seems like there
is some convergence to this.
Should I feel like that
you guys in general
have more accurate votes
than past years somehow.
I don't know.
So let's try to figure
out why it might be that
and what this thing
standard deviation is.
Let's try to figure out
what all these things are.
So the idea is that we're
going to measure some quantity,
but it's a measurement
with error.
And for now, we'll just assume
that the measurement error
is Gaussian distributed, because
otherwise, we get confused
and everything.
So let's say-- so
what we're going to do
is we're going to measure
some quantity with error.
OK, so it's-- Now, what we're
interested in is not really
the width of the
resulting distribution,
because that's a
result of how accurate,
how good we are as
experimentalists.
What we're really interested
in is this true quantity, so
the mean of our distribution.
We want to know mean.
Now, if you read the
supplemental section
of this paper, what
you'll see is that there's
a significant standard
deviation to their measurements,
where the standard deviation,
they don't actually
quote exactly what it is.
But they have plots
of the histograms,
where like, for example,
this is a histogram
of the different growth rate
measurements across those 48
samples, and actually, in this
case, even more than that.
But what you see is that
the standard deviation
might be 3%, 4%.
So the standard deviation is
actually something that's big.
Now the question
is, what we really
want to now is, how the
mean of these distributions
are shifting, because we
want to know something
about this true underlying
growth rate deficit,
because each
individual measurement
is a rather noisy measurement.
And indeed, in this
case, the noise
is larger than the signal.
But if we believe that
we don't have a shifting
systematic error, then
we can average that out
just by making
many measurements.
So the question is,
so the standard error
of the mean, what
it's telling us about
is that if you measure
this quantity n times,
you get some mean.
So let's say that
this is a-- ooh,
it's a little bit of a
broad somehow Gaussian.
So this is a histogram of our
measurements of this thing.
And what we want to know is
the mean of this distribution.
So this is similar to our
discussion of super resolution
microscopy.
And the question is,
how will the mean
be distributed if you
have these n measurements?
It's a Gaussian distribution.
And it's certainly a
Gaussian distribution,
because of course, if
we-- what we're doing
is we're measuring a
bunch of Gaussians.
And we're going to
add them all together.
And then we're going
to calculate the mean.
So we definitely get a Gaussian.
And indeed, because of
the central limit theorem,
this is also saying that
even if your errors were not
distributed super
Gaussian, even if they
were a little bit funny shaped,
the resulting distributions
of the means will look
more like a Gaussian.
Now, what we often plot
is the standard error
of the mean, which is kind
of the plus or minus 1 sigma
of the distribution of the mean.
So if we go and we sample from
this distribution n times,
we'll get some value.
If we sample from
it again, we'll
get some other value, so forth.
Now, the distribution of the
means we're going to calculate
is not going to be
a representation
of the full standard deviation.
But rather, it's
going to be suppressed
by this root n, where n is the
number that we're sampling.
So if you look at the
histogram of the means,
you're going to get a
Gaussian in here-- OK, that's
not a very nice Gaussian,
but-- with a width that
is the standard deviation
divided by root n.
Now, if we assume that we don't
have any systematic error, then
this distribution of means that
you would have calculated--
it's Gaussian, it's
centered on the right value,
but about a third
of the time, it'll
be beyond the plus
or minus 1 sigma.
And what that means is
that about a third of time,
if you plot this standard
error of the mean,
it should fall off of
the kind of true curve.
And this basically
does not depend on n.
And can somebody
say why it doesn't?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think I
was sort of confusing myself,
but this makes sense.
So yeah, I mean, you know that
these error bars will shrink,
if you take more measurements.
But on the other hand,
the actual measurements
will be closer--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: --to the true value.
So what happens is
that as you sample
from this distribution
a larger number n times,
then your error bars shrink,
but your measurements
get closer to the curve.
And those two effects cancel.
So you should end up roughly
with 2/3 of the errors bars
containing this curve,
or 1/3 falling off.
And I think that this is
a little bit surprising,
because there's always a sense
that we feel that there's
something wrong with our
measurements or something
wrong with our model or whatnot,
if any error bar does not
contain the line.
I mean, I feel like I often see
there's this effort that people
have to try to make it so that
these error bars always overlap
with some underlying
curve that is supposed
to represent reality.
But that's not, in principle,
supposed to be true.
Are there any questions
about where we are right now?
OK.
Now, what I want to do is
something slightly different,
which is ask-- let's say that
this is a curve that is not
the underlying reality but
is instead a fit to the data.
How does this change
anything that we've said?
Or does it?
All right, well, OK, let's-- OK,
so we're going to say do fit.
The question is does this
change the thing here?
Do you understand?
Change, A is Yes, B is No.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you have the
same modeling for the fit
as we did for the original--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well, let's say
that this was a curve predicted
by some fancy
theory but that you
have to specify the mass
of something and the-- so I
don't know, there are two
things that are specified.
So what you do is you fit.
And the question
is, does it change
what fraction of the
error bars you expect
to contain the true curve?
Ready?
Is it not clear what I'm asking?
AUDIENCE: But the true curve
is determined by the god.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Right, so the
truth curves-- we don't
need to get too much into this.
But I mean, the
reason we're doing
science is to try to look
into the mind of God, right?
So we were doing
a fit to try to--
AUDIENCE: But you can
fit anything to anything.
You know, what does that mean?
Do you see what I mean?
Like, I could--
AUDIENCE: It
depends on whether--
AUDIENCE: I could
get curve that passes
through each and every
of these points points,
if you give me
enough time with it.
So I guess I don't
understand the question.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: All right, yeah.
OK, but I think you're arguing
for something already maybe.
But let's just say that
this was a-- I mean,
let's just for concreteness
let's say that I measured at 15
values of x.
I have some error
bars and some error.
But then I needed
three parameters
to characterize this curve.
And so those I used to fit.
Are you happier with
three fitting parameters
and 15 measurements?
All right, let's just
see where we are.
OK, ready, 3, 2, 1.
OK, so we have a majority of
A but a significant minority
of B. So just to be
a lot more concrete,
can somebody say why
they're saying yes?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess
intuitively, [INAUDIBLE] we
try to optimize the number of
error bars that go through.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
the fit is somehow
trying to get the curve
to go near the error bars.
And typically when
we do a fit, we're
typically trying to
minimize this mean squared
error or deviation from our
curve to the data point.
How much you expect this
to make a difference?
So for concreteness
again, let's say
that I had 15 values of x that
I was measuring things at.
Now, we expect say five
of them-- five will miss
true curve, we decided roughly.
Now the question is, what
happens if we, instead
of having this true curve, if
we do a fit using these three
parameters?
How much of a difference
should it make to this very,
very roughly?
We'll see-- Now, I'm asking
roughly how many of these error
bars do you expect to then
miss the fitted curve?
And this is we used three
fitting parameters, say.
That was parameters over there.
Do understand the question?
So instead of plotting
this god-given curve,
instead we're plotting
a curve that I'm
giving you, where I use three
fitting parameters to fit
to the data.
And I'm just trying
to get it roughly.
I think that this is
not a rigorous statement
I'm about to make, but
just so that we're all
roughly on the same page.
All right, ready, 3, 2, 1.
Right, so it'll be
somewhere in here.
And I think this
is not quite true.
But the idea is
that, in particular,
if you make n
measurements and then you
use n fitting
parameters, in general
you will get a perfect fit, i.e.
the curve will go
through every single data
point amazingly perfectly.
So if I give you 15
measurements across here
and then I give you a
15-degree polynomial-- I guess,
we only need a
14-degree polynomial
with 15 free parameters--
then that polynomial
will go through everyone of
your data points spot on,
not even a question of whether
it goes through the error bars.
I'm saying
literally-- and that's
just because you're just solving
an equation at that stage.
Now, this is a stupid statement,
except that once you're
kind of like in the
heat of the moment,
eagerly trying to do some
fitting for your advisor
or whatever, it's easy to
fall into this trap, where
you just kind of like
add extra parameters.
I mean, I definitely
remember in graduate school,
I was surprised.
I was like, oh, this thing,
it works wonderfully.
It's like it seems to magically
goes through all my data.
And then I felt very stupid
like 30 seconds later.
But this is just
a very easy thing
to screw up and forget about.
So what this is
saying is that, if you
see a curve-- if in
the course of your work
or if you're reading a
paper and you see some curve
and you want to know something
about how much information is
it or whether things look
reasonable given the data,
it's useful to kind
of orient yourself
relative to these
statements, that depending
on how many free parameters
you're kind of using,
you expect a larger or
smaller number of these data
points to kind of go through
the curve that you see.
But I would just want
to stress that you
don't want to be anywhere close
to the point where you have
a number of parameters
equal to the number of kind
of measurements
that you're making.
And for any sort
of reasonable curve
describing what you
hope is a reality,
you expect some of those data
points with their error bars
to kind of miss the curve.
And that doesn't
mean that they're
sloppy experimentalists.
It doesn't mean whatever.
OK, now coming back
to the task at hand,
do you understand
why they're plotting
the standard error
of the mean rather
than the standard deviation?
Because what your interest
in, in principle, is not--
the question you're
trying to answer
is not how variable
are their measurements
but to what certainty
can they claim
to know the actual god-given,
real cost associated
with expressing these proteins
as a function of the expression
level.
And for that, you really want
to ask about the standard error
of the mean.
Great.
So now, we can come
back and ask about,
why did I just
spend half an hour
talking about standard error of
the mean, standard deviations,
fitting to data?
Well, you guys are probably all
asking yourself that question.
But does anybody have
an answer if I-- Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can fit
with different curves
if you use different things.
PROFESSOR: You can fit with
different curves if you-- yeah,
I think that that's hard
to argue that statement.
But the statement is a little
bit like "different proteins
have different expression
levels," but a little bit more
concrete maybe.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in
this case, I didn't
check their calculations, but
if you have a natural line,
then you can't make this
calculation of optimization.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but I
think that-- right, so--
AUDIENCE: In the sense that
there won't be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So I think that this
is a tricky thing.
The data certainly do argue
for a super linear cost.
But I would say that they
argued for it rather weakly,
in that if you look at their
data and you just fit a line,
you would say, it's maybe OK.
And of course, once
again, should we
be surprised that the
quadratic fits better?
No.
And this is a very
dangerous thing,
if you're comparing models.
It'll always be the case, if
you add another parameter,
it will look better.
But the question then
is how strong of a case
should we make of this?
And then how important is it for
the conclusions of the study?
Now, in addition to the
line and the quadratic,
they had another
curve in here, which
looks like-- let me see if I
can get it right for you guys.
So this is fine, tricky thing.
So it's the dashed
line that looks
very similar to the
solid quadratic line.
Can somebody remind
us what the difference
was between those two
non-linear curves that they had?
Why do they have two curves
that look so similar?
AUDIENCE: I think the dashed
line responds to some model
where there's only so much of
this certain resource that--
PROFESSOR: Right, OK, so my
dashed line is their red line,
just to-- OK dashed
red in the paper.
So it's this line where there's
a finite amount of resources
or protein-making machinery
that the cell has.
And if you use them up, then
you don't get any growth.
And of course, that
statement kind of
has to be true on some level.
And the question is whether--
AUDIENCE: --that scale is--
PROFESSOR: --it's
relevant here, right.
Certainly, I would
say that one question
is whether you can reject
the hypothesis that this cost
function is a line.
Another question is whether you
can distinguish between the two
quadratic or the two non-linear
curves based on the data.
And I think the answer
to the second question
is certainly not.
And they don't
claim that they can.
But it's important to
just note that it's
just impossible for
them to assume--
I mean, those curves are so, so
similar over the entire range
where they have
data that it's going
to be possible to
distinguish those two things.
But does it matter which
of the two cost functions
is the true cost function?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it because
the [INAUDIBLE] where
the marginal
benefits become zero
is like inside the range where
the cost functions are still
exactly the same?
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So what you're saying is that
the two cost functions they
have they behave similarly
over the range that is relevant
maybe, so then therefore,
it doesn't matter.
Is that-- or am I-- OK.
So why do they have to
cost functions there then,
why two non-linear
cost functions?
Just to provide variety
in our modeling?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: They were doing
another experiment later on,
and they said something
like something was saturated
and that was modeled by
the second cost function.
PROFESSOR: Right, yes.
That's right.
And what's the later
experiment they're going to do,
just so that we're--
AUDIENCE: You should
ask somebody else
to explain that, not me.
PROFESSOR: You regret
opening your mouth.
No, OK.
So yeah, so what
is the experiment
that they're going to do?
AUDIENCE: Measuring the benefit?
PROFESSOR: So next, they're
going to measure the benefit.
But this question about
the two cost functions
is not somehow relevant
yet for the benefit part.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So they're doing it
in different concentrations
of lactose and seeing if
the protein expression could
adapt [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right,
after a long time.
So they actually do laboratory
evolution experiments,
where they grow these
bacterial populations
in different lactose
concentrations.
And then they look to see
what level of the lac operon
expression does the
population evolve to.
So what they're
trying to do here
is they're trying
to say, OK, well,
we can measure some cost as
a function of expression.
Maybe we can measure
some benefits
as a function of expression.
And then from that,
we'd like to be
able to predict where the
population will evolve to.
And they had these two
non-linear cost functions,
which based on the data they
have, they can't distinguish.
But they say, oh, well, they're
both kind of reasonable cost
functions.
And in some ways,
maybe the problem
here is that the two
costs functions end up
being wildly different in terms
of predicting what happens
for large lac concentrations,
where you would want
to express more of the protein.
Do you guys-- do you
remember this or not?
Sort of.
And that's actually-- well,
you might as well just
look at that.
So that's figure 4.
That's the normalized
lacZ activity
that the populations
evolve to as
a function of the
lactose concentration
they're evolving in.
And what you see is that
this red curve corresponding
to the finite resources cost
function, it explains the data.
Whereas, the other
ones very much do not.
And that's just because
these other models then
would predict that if you grow
the cells in a lot of lactose
they should express
out to five times
the lac expression, much,
much, much more, which is not
what they see experimentally.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
another way to put
a bound on the expression,
because of this expression
we have?
You mentioned for that
promoter, it's not possible to--
PROFESSOR: OK, but
the idea of evolution
is that evolution can make
it a stronger promoter.
So you guys, one statement
is, given this DNA sequence
at that promoter, how much
expression can you get?
And the most you can get is this
amount that's normalized to 1.
But if you make mutations
in that promoter,
then you could go out further.
So the question now is,
after we kind of tell you
the results of these
evolution experiments,
how much should that favor
this dashed red line,
this super linear cost
function with finite resources?
And on one level, you'd say, oh,
well, that's pretty compelling.
On another level,
later people that
have come and measured this
find that it's basically a line.
So are there any questions?
So it seems to basically be
not true within this range.
It is the case that if
you go out far enough,
then the growth does go to 0.
But that's much further out.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: After they--
on the experiment,
they had [INAUDIBLE] expression
protein at the [INAUDIBLE]
level.
Why didn't they go back and
do the experiment again, just
to see [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
actually, one of these
curves-- so the triangle,
the sort of teal triangle,
it is indeed higher up.
And it's kind of here.
So they do have a data point
that is further beyond and is,
again, above that curve.
So that does provide
somewhat further support
for a non-linear model.
But again, there's a question
of how strong that should be
and so forth.
And indeed, I'd
say, for example,
Terry Hwa has
spent a lot of time
characterizing growth rates as
a function of many, many things.
And if you measure the
relative growth rate
as a function of a non-useful
protein expression--
and what he finds is
that this thing basically
looks like a line in this axis.
And it saturates
at around if you're
at 30% maybe of total
protein expression.
So this is a lot.
But this is kind of where the
cell just can't handle that.
So Terry Hwa has
recently been exploring
a lot of these sort of
phenomenological growth
laws, where he imposes
costs of various sorts
and then looks at how the
cell kind of responds.
And what he finds is just
a remarkably large number
of lines in various spaces
that I find very surprising,
but that he can
understand using kind
of some phenomenological
modeling.
But this is one of
like a dozen lines
that he sees of various
axes doing things.
But the point here is
that, as a function
of the level of expression of
these non-useful proteins, what
he sees is that for a variety of
different proteins-- including
beta-gal but also beta-lactamase
and other proteins that are not
being used in that particular
environment-- what he sees
is that there's
basically a linear cost
growth, as you impose this
non-useful protein expression.
So I'd say that
this basic statement
of it being not-- the statement
of cost being super linear, I
think, ends up not being true.
Now, what does it
mean for this paper?
AUDIENCE: I mean, they still
presented with same hypothesis
and had these data to
back up some of it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So it's a very
interesting hypothesis.
They did nice
evolution experiments,
where they saw the population
adapt to different levels.
But what does it mean
about the predictions,
in particular, in the
sense that if you measure
cost and benefits, then
you want to predict
where it's going to evolve.
What happens?
If it's the case that cost
as a function of expression
is actually linear,
then what does
that mean for their ability to
predict what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: Seems like if
they use their same model
for the benefit in
this linear cost,
that their predictions would
be really off [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So the problem is that if you
actually use a linear function
here, then their
model doesn't even
predict that there should be an
optimum, because their benefit
function ends up also
being essentially
linear with the amount of
this protein expressed.
So if you have two lines-- so
overall growth is something
like goes as
benefits minus costs.
And maybe this is
a relative growth.
So if you have a line here
and a line here, no optimum.
So that's kind of a bummer.
But it doesn't mean that
that's-- in biology,
eventually things
are non-linear,
so there should be some optimum.
And actually, what
I would say is
that I think that the
non-linearity is probably
actually here.
That's the non-linearity
that's relevant,
maybe, is dominated on the
benefit side rather than
the cost side.
My guess as to
what's going on here
is that rather than the
costs growing super linearly
with the expression
level, rather
the benefits will be sub-linear
with the expression level.
And why might that be?
AUDIENCE: We're just
seeing them apart,
splitting up more lactose
that's useful, just so it
can't metabolize more of it.
PROFESSOR: Right, you
know, at some point,
it's just that the cell
doesn't need more sugar.
And then it's not
going to be as useful.
And even before you
get to that regime,
I think there are various
ways in which cells
may be able to use
the sugar more or less
efficiently, depending on how
much they have it, which means
that as-- and this is just
like for us, the first slice
of pizza is great.
But then once you're
at the fifth one,
you start to feel
a little bit full.
So in general benefits as
a function of anything,
should have some
saturating behavior.
And my sense is that
this is basically
why there's an optimum here.
Now, of course, I'd say that
all these cost functions
behave very similarly in here.
So the predictions
that they make in here
are really not very sensitive
to which of the cost functions
they use.
And those are all still
then relevant and valid.
The question is just
trying to predict
what happens beyond the
range that you have data
is very hard, because
it depends very
much on what your curve
does past that region.
So I guess I've made
an argument that I
think that maybe
what's happening
is that the benefit
function here is non-linear.
But what did they actually
do to measure the benefits,
because this is not I think
totally obvious either?
So what should I be plotting?
Well, this is still a
relative growth rate.
And here, this was actually
lactose concentrations.
So this is not lac
expression, which
is the most obvious thing
that you would want to do,
but that's harder.
And what they show
is that their model
is sort of consistent
on this axis.
This is external lactose.
And the idea is
that-- here is 0--
in the absence of any lactose,
if you induce the lac operon,
then you're at this minus
4 and 1/2% or whatnot.
So it kind of starts
out down here.
And then up here, it
comes out up to above 0.1.
So this is the
first 4, maybe 4.5%.
This is up here at 10%.
And you end up with
a curve that kind of
goes from 4% or 5% deficit
up to 10% or 11% advantage.
And this is at full
induction of the lac operon.
What this is saying
is that if you're
making the proteins to break
down and consume lactose,
then there's a cost.
That's just how they plotted it.
But that the benefits do
indeed outweigh the costs
at some concentration
of lactose.
But then here,
there's a saturation.
And here, the saturation
in their model--
they get a saturation
just because
of the dynamics of import.
So what they assume
is that there's
a Michaelis-Menten
kinetics for import.
So the import rate kind of
goes as the concentration
of the lactose divided by some
k plus the concentration again
of lactose, so
Michaelis-Menten dynamics.
But of course, if you have
more of the protein lacY,
then you'll be able
to import more.
So just because
you have saturation
as a function of
lactose does not
mean that you'll have
saturation in terms
of the number of proteins
that you're making.
Do you understand
why I'm saying that?
And indeed, I would say
that many underlying models
could have been consistent
with this data as well.
So I'd say that
their data does not
reject the hypothesis that the
benefit function is sublinear.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that
you just said if you
have more lacY and
import more and it would
saturate to an [INAUDIBLE].
So you could imagine that by
evolution something happened
there.
So why would you even
expect the prediction
of this cost-benefit analysis?
You see what I mean?
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're
saying that evolution
might be able to change
other things as well
to kind of fiddle-- yeah.
I think this is an
important question.
I think the basic
answer is that there
are some things that are
easier for evolution to do
than others.
And also that somethings have
maybe already been optimized.
Now, relevant to
this point, so they
did these laboratory
evolution experiments,
and there was one category of
mutation that they did not see.
Does anybody remember
what that was?
What's the most
straightforward way of kind
of getting around all this
cost-benefit discussion
that we've just had?
So the one thing
that they did not see
was significant
improvements in the enzyme.
So they checked, and they
found that they did not
see any increase the
lacZ activity normalized
by the amount of the
lacZ that was being made.
Now, that might make sense,
because if this enzyme has
already been gone
through millions of years
of optimization to
break down lactose,
then it's reasonable to say,
oh, well, in the next five
generations in the lab,
it maybe won't improve.
Of course, you always have
to be careful about this,
because it could be that some
sequence slash structure is
best when you're thinking
about-- when is it
that E. coli might see lactose?
Our gut.
So you imagine you have
bacteria in the gut.
That's a different
environment than in the lab.
So it could be very
well that the enzyme,
because of the pH and
all these other things,
the enzyme actually
could adapt to the lab,
even though it may have already
been adapted to our gut.
So you have to got to be careful
about this kind of argument
always.
But of course, once you see
the result, then you say,
oh, well, that's
because of this.
So I just want to make
sure that we know what
these experiments look like.
So they went for
500 generations.
So it's useful to ask how
long this experiment should
have taken.
Is it closest to three
days, three weeks?
Anytime you read
about an experiment,
it's useful just to have some
notion of what the authors went
through in order to bring
you the results you're
reading about.
If you are not sure, you
can just make a guess.
OK, ready, 3, 2, 1.
All right, so we have some
number of A's, some number
of B's, and a couple of C's.
Well, one thing
you might say is,
how fast can E. coli divide?
OK, on one level, you may
say oh, about 20 minutes.
That should give us what?
75-ish generations a day.
So we should be able to get here
in a week or something, maybe.
But that's not what they
did, for several reasons.
First of all, this
would be in rich media.
In the environment that
they are doing this in,
it's a bit slower.
But that would get you maybe
to the two or three-week mark.
But that still is
not what happened.
They actually had to
go for three months.
And this is because
experiments are not always
keeping cells
constantly dividing
at their maximal rates.
The standard way
that we do this is
what's known as kind
of daily batch culture.
And does anybody know how
much they diluted by each day?
Yeah, so I think it was
diluting by a factor of 100.
So it's daily batch
culture with 100x dilution,
which corresponds to about
6.6 generations per day.
So this is very
far from what you
would think of as kind of the
best they could possibly do.
And what it means
is that, yeah, it
does take about
three months for them
to have done this experiment.
It also means that if you look
at the number over the course
of each day, this is n max.
And they dilute-- this
is n max over 100--
so they dilute by
a factor of 100.
When you transfer cells
from a saturated state
into new environment, do they
start dividing immediately,
for those of you who have
done this experiment?
No.
It's going to take an hour
or two for them to get going.
But then they're going
to start dividing.
And this on a log scale maybe--
log N. And what you'll see
is they kind of go-- they're
dividing exponentially
and then they saturate.
Indeed, they're going
to saturate for about
a fair amount of time.
So this might be an hour or two.
This might be say five hours.
But then you still have
another roughly 20 hours
to go before the next dilution.
And then we repeat.
So they actually saturated for
a fair fraction of the day.
Now, in all these discussions
of laboratory evolution--
and in many of the
calculations we're
going to be doing over
the next couple of weeks--
we'll typically assume that
what is being optimized
is the growth rate,
the rate of division.
But you can imagine there
being other things that
might possibly be
optimized in the course
of these sorts of experiments.
Can somebody volunteer
what are other things?
AUDIENCE: Maximum density?
PROFESSOR: Right, so
you could imagine,
if you could just eke out
one more division out there,
then you could get an advantage.
And there's a whole set
of interesting things,
these growth advantage.
It's stationary phase
or the GASP mutants,
where the focus is on
trying to do well here.
And also you can
imagine related maybe,
if you do better
out for this period,
cells will start
dying eventually.
So if you have a lower rate
of death at saturation,
then you can also spread.
Other-- yep.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, can I
ask a quick question?
What's a possible reason for
the initial [INAUDIBLE] used
[INAUDIBLE] at the beginning?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So I think it's basically that
when the cells are saturated,
they generally enter a rather
distinct physiological state,
as compared to the
dividing state.
And I think the longer they
sit in this saturated phase,
the longer it's going to
take them to get going
in the next day, for example.
And it's also the case that
cells in saturated culture
tend to be more resistant to
a variety of perturbations
of various sorts-- so if you're
talking about heat, salt, this,
that, and the other thing.
What's something else they
could be optimized here?
If you were imagining
you're a cell,
you want to spread,
what would you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So we're saying that
the media is specified
by the experimentalist.
So you're the cell in
this Gedanken experiment.
AUDIENCE: You'd divide yourself.
PROFESSOR: Right, so you can
eat the other cells, yeah.
Well, and in particular,
actually out here, this
is part of how the
GASP mutants spread,
is that when other
cells start to die,
they lyse their contents.
And then the cells
that are surviving
can actually eat
the contents, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
a way to coordinate
between different cells, so
that they can sort of evenly
distribute themselves
in the media,
so you don't have to many--
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So I'm actually assuming
here it's well mixed,
so that in principle
would not be an issue.
But yeah, so you can
imagine spatial effects
of various sorts being relevant.
I guess I just drew this
up here to highlight
that, in principle, you can
also decrease the lag time.
So if you start
dividing more rapidly
at the beginning of
the day, then you'll
get to spread before
your neighbors
and your genotypes
will indeed spread.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So I just know
so little about cells,
but is it true that
a lot of the cells
could survive and be the same
cell for that whole duration
when they were in
the stationary phase?
PROFESSOR: You're
asking whether the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
whether a cell that
entered the beginning
of the stationary phase,
that same cell would have
a pretty good chance of--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, over I think
this sort of 12-hour type
period, I think
the answer is yes.
But if you go for
an extra day or two,
then I think you can start
getting extensive cell death.
AUDIENCE: Because
then who knows?
Maybe long enough, though, they
would develop a little clock
to let them know that
it was about to split.
PROFESSOR: Yes, right.
Yeah, so people
have thought about--
and I'm not sure if this--
AUDIENCE: And it
seems like it would.
PROFESSOR: --particular
effect is-- yeah, right.
But I just want to mention
that this is something
that you kind of maybe
would expect, indeed,
you see in these-- so they're a
famous set of experiments done
by Richard Lenski at Michigan
State, where he's been dividing
six or eight-- doing daily
batch dilutions of equal E. coli
cultures now for decades.
So he started, I don't
know, late '80s or so.
I don't know if
you guys remember.
So he's gone tens of
thousands of generations
and has seen a bunch
of remarkable things.
One of the things
that he has seen,
as you might have
expected, is a decrease
in the lag time of
the vector area.
So what we have now is a
situation where they add IPTG,
so that all the cells
are in principle
start out expressing
the lac operon.
And then they grow
the cells over time.
And what they see is that the
lacZ activity, it starts out
at being 1, normalized,
for all the cultures,
because there's IPTG,
so it doesn't matter
how much lactose there is.
But what they see
is that over time,
they see things
that look like this.
So the 0.5 millimolar lactose
didn't change very much.
But if you look at some of
the others, like no lactose,
there was significant
decrease in expression.
Whereas, up here at, for
example, 2 millimolar lactose,
they see an increase.
So what you see is
that there really
are evolutionary changes
of these strains, because--
and it's very, very
relevant that they
had IPTG in the media.
So if they did this
experiment without IPTG,
do you have any sense of
what would kind of happen
to the cells?
I mean, how would that
change the results?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: The
expression level would
be determined by [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so
the expression would
be determined by the lactose.
But let's say that
after 500 generations,
we put them all in a
millimolar lactose.
How different do you
think they're going to be?
I mean, do think that the
culture grown, for example,
in the absence of
lactose, do you
think that it would still be
able to eat lactose after 500
generations in that experiment?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes, OK.
And yeah, so what's
the difference?
I mean, why are you
saying yes or what's the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know how hard it is--
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah, right.
So this is an
experiment with IPTG.
And now, I'm just trying
to think about or imagine
what would have happened if they
had done the same experiment
without IPTG just growing
in that environment,
in particular, if you grow minus
IPTG and then minus lactose
for 500 generations?
And then what I
want to ask is, OK,
let's say that you go over
there and you just add lactose.
Will the cells, do you think,
be able to grow and the lactose?
OK.
And so why is it that here
the answer seems to be no?
So here, we have
evolved a population
that not only it's not
expressing the lacZ
activity here.
But indeed, if you put lactose
in there, it doesn't express.
So these cells can no
longer grow on lactose.
So what's the key
difference here?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So I mean, there's
no [INAUDIBLE] in this case.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Now I think this is
just really important.
So in this case, there is
approximately, we'll say,
no cost to having the lac operon
on there, because it's just not
being expressed.
So then the only
cost is associated
with DNA replication.
So the advantage associated
with shutting off or removing
the ability to grow on lactose
is just really minimal.
And indeed, in this culture, the
authors did say, what happened.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the entire
gene is diluted, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So it was almost a kB was
just removed from the genome.
And that kB included
the promoter.
And so that it just-- yeah.
So it's not going to be able
to grow on lactose anymore.
But the key thing
is here, these cells
were subject to this
5% cost associated
with making the lac operon,
which means that that mutant
that appeared, it
had a 5% advantage,
and so it was able to spread
throughout the population.
Whereas, what they could see is
that the evolved lacZ activity
indeed was different,
depending on how much lactose
they had in the culture.
And this is in the
presence by IPTG,
so they removed
that feedback loop.
And in these experiments,
anyway you slice it,
the normalized lacZ activity did
not go above around 1.2 or 1.3.
So there is some
non-linearity that is somehow
constraining those
cells from going up
to increased expression very
much beyond the wild type.
We are out of time,
but on Tuesday, we'll
start talking about
evolution, and in particular,
in the context of
neutral evolution,
as kind of a null model to try
to understand these dynamics.
And we will also
talk more about why
it takes as long as it
does before you start
seeing anything happening here.
If you have any questions,
please feel free to come on up.